Spare some change?
Sorry, man,
I got nothing.
All right.
[siren wails]
Hold it right there.
[car door closes]
Let's see some ID.
I wasn't even doing anything,
man.
Are you talking back to me?
No, I was just walking, man.
Look, there is no reason
for you to get upset, sir.
I'm not.
All right, that's it.
Put your hands on your head.
Put my hands--
Put your hands
on your head, yes!
You had your chance.
Listen, man,
can I just ask you,
like, politely what it is
that I did?
- Think I was born yesterday?
- Come on, man, I--
Get in the car.
Duck your head.
Aah!
Ahh.
[groans]
[bottles clink]
All right, Officer,
I'll take it from here.
Oh, hi, Wally.
Good to see you.
He's all yours.
All right.
What?
[chuckles]
Y'all have a good night.
All right.
Thanks, man,
but where we going?
I'm glad you asked.
Follow me.
Through there?
[shouts]
[magical tune]
[laughs]
Whoa, look at this place.
Where are we?
Just be patient,
and I'll show you.
Your suit changed.
♪ Follow me
to a place I know ♪
♪ Where there ain't no pain
and no sorrow ♪
♪ It's a place to be
if your skin is brown ♪
♪ I'm talking 'bout Negrotown
[cheerful music]
Negrotown?
What, like, Atlanta?
[laughs]
Almost.
Now be quiet while I sing.
♪ In Negrotown,
you can walk the street ♪
♪ Without getting stopped,
harassed, or beat ♪
♪ And there's always a cab
when you need to get around ♪
And they always stop.
♪ In Negrotown
♪
I think I'm getting it.
It's like a utopia
for black people.
Yeah!
But seriously,
shut the fuck up.
♪ You won't get followed
when you try to shop ♪
(all)
♪ You can wear your hoodie
♪ And not get shot
♪ No white folks
to cross the street in fear ♪
(all)
♪ No trigger-happy cops
♪ Or scared cashiers
(Jordan)
♪ That loan application
♪ Can't get turned down
♪ You're always approved
in Negrotown ♪
This is amazing!
I know, right?
(women)
♪ We're going down
to Negrotown ♪
♪ Where the strong black men
are raining down ♪
♪ There's light skin,
dark skin, every shade ♪
♪ And there's no white bitches
to take them away ♪
♪
This sounds too good
to be true.
- It does, doesn't it?
- Yeah.
But can a nigga
finish a song?
Oh.
I mean,
can a nigga finish?
I'm sorry.
♪ In Negrotown,
you live long and well ♪
♪ There's no disease,
no sickle cell ♪
♪ No stupid-ass white folks
touching your hair ♪
♪ Or stealing your culture,
claiming it's theirs ♪
♪ Hanging out in a group
doesn't make you a gang ♪
♪ Every word that you say
ain't considered slang ♪
♪ No one trying to get in
on the latest trend ♪
♪ By making you
their token black friend ♪
♪ There's a place
where harmony is found ♪
(all)
♪ It's a motherfucking
black playground ♪
♪ Talking 'bout Negrotown
(all)
♪ Talking 'bout Negro
♪ Talking 'bout
Negro, Negro, Negro, Negro ♪
♪ Talking 'bout Negrotown
[song ends]
[eerie humming]
(man in the distance)
Sir? Sir? Sir?
Sir?
[groans]
Wha--
All right, get up.
- Wha--
- Let's go, get up.
[groans]
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, whoa, whoa,
hold on, wait.
I thought I was going
to Negrotown.
Oh, you are.
[piano music]
♪
[door closes and engine starts]